[Music]
my name is kirsten moss i'm the dean of
admissions and financial aid i must say
i have been looking forward to this i
don't know if the panelists know this
but i have been looking forward to this
all week
i've had the great pleasure of admitting
a couple folks on the panel and also
catching up with our alumni so i'm
looking forward to hearing what they've
been up to it's
special time of year for me to reconnect
with our community
so today's session is really your
opportunity to learn about the gsb
experience
from our current students and alumni
kelsey
would you lead us off hi everyone my
name is kelsey
it's crazy to think that it was just two
years ago that i was sitting in your
shoes
in boston attending this panel so time
really flies
but i'm just finished my first year at
the gsb
and i'm currently in boston today i'm
working remotely for a
luxury retail tech company based in
london so came back to the east coast to
be a little bit closer in time zone
but i graduated brown in 2014 and then
came back to boston
at to work at cambridge associates which
is a financial services
and investment management company where
i worked on venture capital research and
then ultimately joined a venture firm
for about six months before starting at
gsb so
gsb was really my first entry out
out of the new out of the new england
area and it's been a wonderful
experience
as far as academics i actually one of my
favorite classes this year was in the
spring quarter so on zoom which
they may be shocking for many people
that that was one of my favorites but
um it was the consumer behavior course
by professor hong
and we which focuses on consumer
psychology and then
the means by which we can influence
consumer behavior
so really a lot
professor wong's energy and uh was
infectious and that probably
had a lot to do with that being one of
my favorite classes but it
was a wonderful experience it's
wonderful to meet you
awesome and um we see the first
questions coming in so feel free to
continue with those and i'll go get to
them in about 20 minutes so lad
how about you what was your favorite
academic experience hi everyone i'm lad
it's a pleasure to be here
uh it's fitting that i'm going right
after kelsey here because my favorite
academic experience
also involves professor wong or sushi as
as we called her she was the faculty
advisor on the
step exchange program with singua
university
in beijing that i got to participate on
so during the week of thanksgiving
last year 30 of us went to
beijing and basically took a series of
classes uh kind of short condensed
classes or lectures
from professors or from business leaders
in beijing
and my favorite moment from that
experience was speaking with a senior
strategy leader
at a tech company called meituan which
is a combination
of food delivery yelp reviews
and kind of a booking.com online super
app
and it was simultaneously familiar
uh but very different in how the tech
ecosystem the consumer internet evolved
in china um
and understanding why it did and how
that affected their strategy
and their organizational design uh in
that context in that culture
was really a nice capstone to learn
applying a lot of the core learnings
that we talked about mostly in the us
context
awesome thank you lad how about are you
michael
yes yeah so it's good to be here with
everyone good to be here with the other
panelists some of i know pretty well uh
it's i'm michael o'leary i
graduated from harvard in 12 i studied
philosophy there i worked at bain
capital and private equity initially and
then when deval patrick left
office in 2015 as governor of
massachusetts to join main capital to
launch
an impact fund i joined him in that
effort so worked at brain capital double
impact
uh for a couple years and then went to
stanford um and graduated last year more
recently
i just finished a book um i'll use this
opportunity to plug the book it comes
out
in august august 18th it's called
accountable the rise of citizen
capitalism
it's about impact investing divestment
corporate social responsibility and the
rest
um my favorite academic experience part
of the reason i went to
uh the gsb was in
pivoting a little bit towards economic
policy getting a better understanding of
that
and there is an amazing lecturer at the
gsb i'm sure
many folks here took a class with him
keith hennessey
who is the former director of the
national economic council kind of the
top economic policy making body
uh in the white house for a number of
years during the great recession
um and uh in one of the first classes i
took with him
he had us prepare uh around the
immigration crisis
it was when there's all the detention
happening at the board of migrant
detention centers
um and he cold called on me to start
answering
um and then said actually let's do it
the way we would have done it in the
white house
walk with me and we did a west wing
style walk and talk
around the room as he peppered me with
questions i had nothing no notes to go
off of
which was i would say partly inspiring
partly humiliating
but very memorable so i'll leave it
there
thank you michael how about you charles
yeah
um hey everyone it's it's great to meet
you over there i guess virtually and um
uh yeah pleasure to be here so i i just
finished my first year
at the gsb i'm also pursuing a joint
degree with the
environment and resources program so
that's called e-iper happy to take any
questions on that
um i studied at yale for undergrad i
studied mechanical engineering
i worked in management consulting for a
few years and then went to work in
offbridge solar
in east africa and part of my
thinking with coming to to the gsb in
stanford was to
start to pivot more towards the clean
energy and climate space
in an operator roller capacity so i'm
interning right now at a an energy
storage startup that's actually based in
cambridge massachusetts called malta so
doing that internship remotely as it's
the state of the world right now but
i'm really thrilled to have the
opportunity to just kind of continue on
this path that
stanford has really facilitated um i
would say
uh favorite academic experience of the
past year uh was
what we call like an across the street
class so it was actually a class
at the school of engineering but has a
heavy gsb kind of pipeline of students
it's called stanford energy ventures
and you basically if you've heard of
classes like startup garage or lean
launchpad it's
sort of an energy focused version of
that that's led by um
dave danielson who who's an investor at
breakthrough energy ventures so
you know quite specific to that world
but there was this phenomenal
opportunity to work
on a uh sort of a real world application
for
for the climate space um and again yeah
happy to talk more to that but
it's been really eye-opening awesome
thank you
how about you saron hi everyone it's
nice to meet you my name is sharon
tessel
i am originally from houston texas but
went to harvard for undergrad and
after that did consulting um at bain co
and then came to bain capital
uh which i was the place i worked at
before gsb and the place i worked at
after
i'm currently a principal on our
investment staff focused on consumer
opportunities and my favorite class at
the gsb was actually a class called
winning writing
it's taught by a man named glenn crayman
who's
a former new york times editor a former
stanford alum
and i really loved it because i suck at
writing uh unlike michael leary on the
panel who has written a book everyone
should go by
um i i really enjoyed the class because
it gave you really practical
understanding about how to actually
write more effectively
whether it's something like giving
somebody a formal review or how to write
a potential founder you're trying to
meet um and so i found it to be a really
practical
class and i really enjoyed it because uh
he would basically force you to put your
writing up on the screen and have
everyone critique it
and just having um really rich uh folks
from the new york times join in on many
of the classes to give us advice i
thought was
particularly helpful and and uh you know
one of a kind opportunity to have new
york times writers actually edit my work
really cool
thanks and enjoy i was gsb class of
2015. i also did a dual degree with the
princeton school of public and
international affairs
i was harvard undergrad class of 09 and
prior to the gsb i actually worked in
both government as well as in the
private sector
across the us and asia and africa so
i was really excited to um one of my
favorite classes at the gsb
was actually managing growing
enterprises with irv growth spec
and part of the reason it just really um
was so useful is because when i was sort
of thrown in the deep end and my first
management job in asia actually working
for
groupon china which meitwan which lag
had
referenced was an early groupon copycat
which has now become
you know many hundreds of times more
successful and
doing very well in the chinese market
but when i was there i remember
being in charge of like 100 people not
knowing at all what to do making
all the mistakes and taking that class
actually gave me such a great
context for what i had experienced back
in the day of
when i was first in that position and
also knowing going forward what to do
better
and professor grosbeck would really put
us on the spot i think similar to what
michael is talking about um with keith
hennessey he would say okay
so you basically have to like stand up
now you have to give a speech you have
to tell the entire department they just
got laid off or now you have to
like give this pr talk because something
really tragic happened now you just have
to tell us like you know tell these
people what happened to their family
member
um and those are things that are very
jarring and very difficult conversations
but as a leader
and even now as a founder especially
with covin and all these other things
that you just can't foresee i think a
lot of those
skills and a lot of that preparation has
just been so
valuable um and as for what i'm doing
now actually after the gsb i joined
another startup as the first employee
and then after a few years of that i
started my own company where i'm
currently
still running it as the ceo and
co-founder of hilarious global we're a
talent marketplace that both reverses
the brain drain and
puts people who are global leaders into
high impact roles so we'll
help a lot of um let's say american
pharma companies hire for their head of
aipac or will help even
a lot of companies based in indonesia or
singapore hire multilingual talents
maybe many of you in the future
who can help them do global expansion so
really exciting
thank you that's fantastic thank you all
for taking time to introduce yourself
one of the things that we see is pretty
typical for our student graduates
is pivots whether it's pivoting industry
geography function sometimes all three
the vast majority of our students
will pivot at least one if not more of
those however there's also a group
and many coming from private equity who
come in as investors and leave as
investors
so i wanted to start with you lag
because you followed that path
why did you especially knowing you may
want to go back to investing
why did you decide to pursue an mba and
why at stanford
and maybe i'll ask saron too given your
similar path
what your insights are and the value
oh i think you're on mute clad
there we go okay awesome all right um so
yeah i
i was really excited about an mba um
first of all because
it's a chance to go back to a learning
environment and be around
surrounded by some of the the best
intellectual minds in
in business uh whether it's professors
or the classmates
and that kind of learning environment is
is not something that you get in the
same way in the
work environment but the deeper reason
is that
uh i think business school presented a
chance for me to do a lot of
introspection and growing um
basically understanding the person that
i wanted to become um not just
a business leader but a person and then
learning
uh how to get there and i don't think
i'm not there yet but stanford has given
me a lot of ways to
try and answer that question a lot of
ways to grow um and i was very fortunate
that my employer
virtue partners also believes in the
long-term personal development
of business school and so they uh create
space in their
in their pipeline to allow for that was
there one experience
lab that helped you grow or be more
introspective if you
concrete yeah absolutely uh there's
there's an arc of an
arc of experience that i like to i like
to talk about and it starts
at the very beginning with leadership
laboratories um which for me was
the first time i got to experiment with
like who i was and how i came across as
both a teammate and a leader
and the feedback i got was on much more
how i show up as opposed to
feedback on a work product which i had
been used to in my professional career
and that's the starting point
understanding who i was
uh and then from there um you know
touchy feely or interpersonal dynamics
was a great uh kind of starting point to
understand how relationships are built
and how i show up in those and how i can
be a better communicator
and then the the next step of the arc
was i was an artbocal fellow which meant
that in my second year
i got to coach the first years in the
leadership laboratories class
and i'm one-on-one as a as a their
personal leadership coach
and so the person with the coach idea of
coaching and self-coaching
is how you actually change as a person
as you set a vision of who you want to
become
and then you create steps to get there
and then you hold yourself accountable
or find the support you need to get
there and so that arc
was really powerful to me and again i
don't i don't walk away from the gsb
with like complete satisfaction or
knowledge about who that person i want
to be is or that i'm even close to it
but i walk away a lot more confident
because i have the tools and
the knowledge to take a step down that
direction every day
awesome thanks lad how about you sir on
yeah um i totally agree with lad i think
for me um
part of my decision for going to
business school is really learning how
to lead and learning how to be an
authentic
version of myself and using that to get
people to follow me eventually in my
career as you
go from executor to actually be a
manager and leader at a firm and so
i think that's one big reason i think
the second big reason why i wanted to go
to business school
was also because um i think to be a
great investor is also it's all about
pattern recognition
and i think the gsp and business school
programs provide
a great opportunity to learn about lots
of different businesses lots of
different business problems
um and learn from those micro stories to
actually extrapolate that to your future
life and so
for me i felt like i got so much
learning in two years i couldn't
replicate in any other way even in my
day job or
um you know in other work experiences
and so for me i felt like
i could learn so much from my classmates
um and i think that makes me a better
business person and better investor over
the long run and i think even to this
day i go back to my classmates and i ask
them
plenty of questions about industries i
don't understand or i remember them
talking about x topic
um or they work at x job and so i found
that to be particularly powerful
not only while i was at the gsp but even
uh you know four or five years out
that's cool thank you joyce i'm going to
turn to you
one of the things stanford is known for
is its community
and now you've had a little time to be
out as an alumni
looking back how would you describe the
community and how has it impacted you as
an alumni now
i think um well it's impacted me in all
sorts of really incredible ways this
year would have actually been my fifth
year reunion
and because of course um you know the
the on-campus plans that we originally
had were changed but it was really
inspiring to see
how much the community found ways to
have i
helped organize a virtual zoom reunion
i've caught up with a lot of classmates
and i'll still
i think at least on a weekly basis have
at least some check-in
with a gsb classmate either because
other classmates were founders sort of
talking through resources
introducing investors to each other
giving each other advice for feedback
as well as um i've been part of women's
circles
and in the boston area especially i
noticed some people asking about the
alumni community
it's very strong and it's very mighty in
some ways because
it's a slightly smaller community than
in the bay area but what i found very
special is that my women's circle
included gsb
alumnae who ranged in age from
early mid 60s to early 30s
and everything in between and so that
level of diversity and also the
really deep authentic connections we can
have because we're part of the same
community we have that shared
background and we're willing and able to
be very open and vulnerable with each
other it was just so special and
something i never could have gotten just
from meeting someone else
kind of in regular day-to-day life who
was in a different
generational stage than i was in so i
thought that was incredible
um and i guess the adjectives i often
use is just
really mutually supportive um there's a
high
sense of obligation almost whenever i
reach out to other gs beers
whether it's in like indonesia or if
it's in new york or elsewhere
um the response rate is almost 100
percent even if it's a cult outreach
because i think there's just that
feeling of community and wanting to
give back to each other so i i found it
really incredible
joyce you want to tell just briefly what
a women's circle is in case someone
doesn't know
oh sure um a women's circle is basically
a group of
women who are alumni at the gsu female
identifying gsb members
and the alumni association will help
sort of match people together
and so you'll sign up regionally and
they usually have like a once a year
intake and you just have to commit for
the full year
we usually meet once every six weeks
relatively um
like basically four to eight weeks
usually six weeks
and it's a group of people usually
around six to eight members who just
share
um there's some sometimes there's some
like agenda that might be recommended
but each circle evolves in its own way
and it's all just
volunteer driven and it's just a great
way to find other
i guess alumni and have community and
talk about issues ranging from personal
to professional and everything in
between
awesome um kelsey since you're still
on campus and in it what your first year
with the community what surprised you
what what strikes you
i think i think immediately from
the minute you walk onto campus it's
going back going back to school and
meeting 400 new people
you've it's a little bit shocking to the
system you haven't done that in a long
time
[Laughter]
and i and recognize you immediately
feel welcomed and at home with it
because people are so warm and excited
and want to get to know you for
for who you are and what your passions
are and i think stanford does a really
good job at building a community
people who celebrate each other's
differences and aspirations
and want to lift each other lift each
other up in every sense and so
you'll immediately have about 40 coffees
on your calendar as you're trying to get
to know all of your classmates a little
overwhelming
but you but ultimately it's
that's what creates that core community
having that smaller class size i will
say
incentivizes you to really reach
um reach out at the beginning because
you feel that sense
i can meet everyone in my class and and
even
create a broad network in the class
above me before i graduate
so that's a that's a pretty motivating
factor
and then i will say i was actually i was
on campus this spring as well
living in the residences and i think i
i was so inspired by my class this
the in the spring quarter both the up
um how both
opera um how they both remained
opportunistic as well as optimistic
during that quarter we were able to
really build this
this new form of community both
virtually
and then safely in person whether it be
walks instead of coffee chats and
arbuckle or
zoom foam sessions where we're playing
online games
instead of the age-old tuesday bar
nights that you'll hear about from all
the alums and i think
that was that's community to me to be
able to rise in it
during a period that's so dark
for the world i think
that was the gsp was one of the happiest
places i think
in the nation in the world this spring
and i can't speak to enough the
importance of that community and the
ability to create that
in those types of times thank you kelsey
charles i'm going to move to you um cold
call how have
people often ask about our leadership
development and i know that's
distinctive as well at stanford
how have you grown as a leader from your
experience at the gsb
yeah um it's a great question thanks for
the cold call kirsten
a big takeaway i've had from both you
know the traditional
almost you know lecture classroom
discussion format but also some of these
more applied classes like leadership
labs is just
the importance of authenticity and just
really knowing yourself well
your strengths your weaknesses how you
come across to others
that's just been such a repeated theme
that in a way that i haven't thought as
much about in my
prior professional experience um one
story that just
popped into my mind as we were talking
on this panel was
in leadership labs so the way they
structure it is
you typically you have a weekly almost
case study
with your with your squad which is a
small group of um
six of your classmates within your
section and your sections
around about 80 or 90 uh people in total
so it's kind of subdivisions within your
overall class but
in your squad each week you basically
role play different leadership scenarios
and
uh i came into one of these cases midway
through the my first the fall quarter
and i everyone reads a different case
study a different perspective and role
they take on and i was a co-founder of a
tech company in this case
um start with the lighting it's uh sun's
coming out over here
um and uh and i walked into this
conversation with my
i'd read my case study i felt good about
the talking points i wanted to hit we
were trying to raise more money for
investors
and basically midway through the case
study um or the simulation i was fired
at uh point blank and it was it totally
caught me off guard i hope i'm not
ruining any surprises for
for future case studies or lead lapse
but it it just
it threw me so off guard and i kind of
was like a deer in headlights and i lost
sense of
and it wasn't it wasn't meant to you
know it wasn't meant to put me on the
spot to sort of put me in a
but it really just it was like a good
stress test of like how do i handle this
difficult situation
how do i work with my co-founder to try
and bring us back to
from this difficult uh scenario and
afterwards you had like great some of
the best debrief conversations with my
squad about
what that you know how to handle that
from different perspectives in the room
um and how to sort of stay true to
yourself amidst
uh you know a difficult situation so
uh hopefully i didn't scare anyone but
it was like a tremendously good learning
uh
moment and um yeah
it taught me a lot fantastic what a
great example
thank you and michael tell me um
all of you know at stanford we believe
that you really do have the power to
change the future
so how has the gsb influenced
you know your sense of of that power
um small question
[Laughter]
how will we all change the world well
just how
you know you're doing something
entrepreneurial
yeah um you know i think it's a
tremendous privilege
to be able to go to a place like
stanford be able to take two years off
from your career
um to kind of lift your eyes to the
horizon a little bit um
and i think being in a place like
stanford especially i you know i went in
i got the advice from a stanford alum
when i was asking you know uh before i
got to campus he was saying
you don't have to know what you want to
do at stanford but it's helpful if you
know what you don't want to do
that helps you you know restrict down to
a narrow set of activities um
and the one thing i knew i didn't want
to do was entrepreneurship you know of
all the interests i knew that one i can
write off
um and yet being around everyone who is
um
you know being in silicon valley i think
being in a culture that is
so risk seeking so tolerant of failure
um
so inclusive that i think it ended up
increasing my risk tolerance
much higher you know my i had a
relatively traditional background before
getting to the gsb
i'd worked in private equity you know
even my pivot towards impact investing
happened within the private equity firm
i was already at
um i think being around so many people
um who are willing to take on so much
risk
uh in their careers uh helped me to get
a little bit more outside of my comfort
zone
and think about you know i of all the
things i imagined doing
after the gsb taking a year off to write
a book was not one of them and now
in helping to launch a new fund also not
one of them um yeah i was planning going
back to the private equity firm i was at
before
and i attribute a lot of that to just
being in the culture um
uh being in the culture of the gsb and
um
and i and you know i don't think i'd be
in the position i am now if a lot of
that had not rubbed off on me
right joyce how about that question to
you
oh gosh also i agree that it's not a
small question i i think um it really
part of it is almost the confidence to
feel
that you really can do anything and if
you try for it
and fail it's okay like michael is even
saying that uh
lack of risk aversion because oftentimes
it's a perception of what you're capable
of
and um we sometimes don't know the full
extent until we try and so i think that
there is that risk risk-taking element
but it's not necessarily like oh you
have to go be an entrepreneur
i felt it was more if there's something
that you see the world needs
and that you're uniquely positioned to
offer then why not
you know don't wait for someone else to
do it why not you and that
was that feeling that extra level of
support and i think confidence boost
that i needed to
to do that myself awesome i'm gonna hit
on two questions one person each
uh really quickly and then turn it over
to the audience's question
we are known at stanford for having um
at any given point 85 percent of
students are taking
classes across the street we also 20 are
doing joint degrees and believing that
problems can be solved where disciplines
cross so
maybe charles you could speak to that
given you're in the joint program
how has this impacted your learning your
approach to your career
yeah i would say it's it's a hugely
valuable aspect of
the the gsb education um really can't
overstate it i mean
with my particular interest coming in
wanting to explore the broader
energy and climate space there's so many
schools at stanford that
touch on the similar themes and and
really are at the cutting edge of a lot
of different areas of research but
i mean even more broadly a lot of my
classmates uh are taking
we'll take across the street class
classes throughout
each quarter just to scratch different
intellectual itches or explore
you know professional interests in
different areas
and uh and you know in some cases there
are joint degrees that that pair up
really nicely as well
to deepen those interests so um
you know i mentioned that one class
earlier stanford energy ventures i
i basically paired up with a a phd
mechanical engineering
student who had helped to develop with
one of stanford's engineering professors
a much better set of algorithms to
control the way wind farm
turbines face oncoming wind to increase
their energy output
by um by quite a significant amount and
but it's so much more than an
engineering problem
it draws an investor interest it the
operators of wind assets get really
interested because they don't expect
their energy production levels to have
decreased to the extent that they have
done for especially for older projects
so
through this class um we worked on a
team with us with several gsb students
but engineering students um
and a couple of undergrads as well who
were more on the programming side
to to sort of refine this potential
product for the market
um so examples like that i think about
awesome and last quick question for
anyone who wants to raise their hand
extracurriculars certainly can add a
meaningful impact to your
life at the gsb does anyone want to
share something that was particularly
important to them outside the classroom
go for it that
yeah so i got involved with the student
mba student association which is our
student government
uh and i served on our diversity
committee for four quarters so quite a
bit of time
and um i was you know it ended up being
a big part of my gsb experience which
taught me a lot uh about you know our
broader
society the gsbs institution but also
myself and the people around me but one
of the things that we did
on the diverse committee was start a new
program
for the class below us so charles and
kelsey went through this
but it was called gsb pods and the
intent behind
it was to take what stanford is really
good at which is bringing
people together in small groups and
going deep and getting past
superficial conversations really getting
to know each other as
people and kind of seeing our
differences and appreciating them and
then finding other ways to connect as
humans
and the idea behind it is that we do
that and we create trust with people we
might not have otherwise
kind of socially or interpersonally
connected with and that trust allows us
to have
deeper and more meaningful conversations
especially about topics that
are sometimes tough to talk about such
as identity or politics
and so we kicked it off we designed it
and launched it this past year
uh we got a lot of great feedback from
kelsey and charles and then have passed
it on to their class
for the next iteration which i'm very
excited about yeah and it really is a
phenomenal story because we're
continuing
we hope that that will continue on
forever at the gsb
so i didn't know lad that you were one
of the folks who did that a big thanks
all right i'm gonna switch yeah because
i'm going to switch now to
questions um and we're getting a lot
because this is a boston
focused panel so to the panelists in the
boston
area we'd like to know more about how
much
did attending business school in the
west coast impact your career
opportunities and network
and the east coast and i've heard that
quite a bit when i'm on the road
because i know many of our graduates
stay in the west coast area the bay area
for a couple years post graduation and
slowly move back
how did that impact your career search
and just raise your hand if you want to
speak to that
any other panelists okay yeah so i mean
i
um from a job perspective obviously i
went back to the same firm but just
talked to my classmates that ended up
back in boston
i think it ends up being an advantage
because oftentimes you're competing
against less people to get the jobs on
the east coast uh because
they're we probably still skew our
alumni definitely still skews towards
the west coast
but i also found moving back here in
2016 until now
that the gsb community in boston is
still very strong
and you often find lots of relationships
across classes so like when joyce
uh was living here she's recently moved
but um you know we hung out and grabbed
dinner
uh even though we weren't in the same
class and i feel like that the great
thing about the dsp is that you do have
great you can
get to know everyone in your class but
also gives you an opportunity to know
people
above you or in classes below you and so
from my perspective a lot of my close
friends in boston actually went to the
gsb but we're in different classes and
so even though
it may be a slightly smaller community
here in boston it's pretty tight-knit
and you can still find great folks um to
sort of share in that experience with
right michael did you want to say
something as well yeah
yeah i think there's a small thing i
would add off my you know long year as
an alumni
now um would be that uh
i think people it's wrong to focus on
like a number of people because i think
the amazing thing about
um the stanford community is um is like
the extent to which people go
um out to help each other i've never had
a time where i reached out to a stanford
alum
and um didn't get a response and i think
about one of the most vibrant alumni
chapters of
any school i've ever witnessed was
stanford gsb in hong kong when i lived
in hong kong for a year
um and had i don't know 15 coffee chats
with people after i got in who just
wanted to meet me and and talk to me
about
stanford so i think that the strength of
the tie um
for me has been really important that's
great i'm going to take a question from
sophie
for those who pivoted industries after
the gsb so she's mentioned kelsey
and joyce what resources did you find at
gsb
enabled you to make the transition so
kelsey do you want to go first
yeah and actually this is ties into the
last question as well because
actually um actually the startup that
i'm working for in the uk
i found it because one of my classmates
wife
just graduated from hbs and interned
there last year so it really does
your network is very expansive all over
it's not it's not just confined to your
class or your school
people are willing to go to all ends to
connect you with the right people
and so i think that's just an important
important caveat
but i uh for me just in terms of
pivoting i
i came into stanford wanting to explore
something in the retail tech sector
and then i ended up testing a lot of
hypotheses all at once both
different countries it's a very early
stage startup i came from a
much larger established firm and a
completely different industry and
i think that's to labs earlier appointed
is the stanford environment that pushes
you to take these risks and you
end up in completely different different
areas than you would have anticipated
and i think
incredible career services to
and specifically grace who's an amazing
career
uh in council in the consumer sector
generally and
she you have plenty of
opportunities to have one-on-one
sessions with the career services office
and they'll
push you to really question you well
what are you trying what are you trying
to test
where do you see yourself this is you
know this is your time to experiment and
think about
what you could do and challenge yourself
to
challenge yourself to think bigger and
so i think that was
incredible in terms of resources and
then of course the network that you get
from
gsb as well um i just was speaking with
grace
recently and they mentioned during kova
they had tracked how many coaching
sessions they had
and there's only 400 students in a class
but in six weeks they had done over 300
one-on-one sessions so it just gives you
a sense of
just how available you know the staff
are there to help you but how about you
joyce
well echoing how great the staff is in
the cmc the career management center
even as alumni
you're eligible for i believe one or two
coaching sessions um
per month and so or per year and as an
alum i also still
use the resources like for example one
of my coaches
was the founder and ceo of a company
that
like in some ways does a lot of things
that are similar to what we're doing but
like you know
many stages ahead new sector alliance
and so she's just a great social
entrepreneur
and a very strong female leader that i
both look up to and get a lot of great
advice from
so i think those resources um
mostly it's around the alumni network
and
also the people who are available for
coffee
chats whether it's in hong kong or to
give you advice um i also have heard
people describe it as like a gold stamp
like oh
they went to stanford even if they're
changing careers or geographies industry
they've never done this before but they
must be like you know hard-working and
capable and smart and all these things
so people are really willing to
give you that bit of halo effect um
sometimes i felt like maybe
undeservingly so
but i was a lucky beneficiary of that so
it does allow for pivoting
in a way that i think without um maybe
some of that
halo effect it would have been a bit
more challenging uh so
you know that's what i found and also i
also really miss you sir on but
now that i've even though i've moved
ironically i've only seen people
virtually so i'm still
doing all of my um boston women's groups
chat to buy a zoom because
all members are doing it via zoom so i
actually still feel very connected
my youngest brother is in college in
boston so i was planning to go out very
frequently so i will
see you next time in person hopefully
yes exactly
exactly um someone is asking from the
audience to
for one of you to talk about your most
unique experience at the gsb
and how did it change you personally or
professionally
that's an interesting word unique there
anybody want to take a stab at that
i might have to cold call you michael um
i your
your talk on junk food it wasn't just
junk food he's gotten
thousands of hits does that qualify as a
unique opportunity
i don't know other schools that do that
maybe you can chat about that
because i've seen it i thought it was
great oh thank you i appreciate that yes
so
there's a wonderful program at dgsb
called low key notes
little keynotes um the idea is uh you
you join
um and you kind of give a ted talk um
style presentation it's like
eight to twelve minutes up on a stage
um and what's great about it i think is
for me like a lot of the folks went up
at the gsb
the last time you did real public
speaking was like in high school or in
college i mean a lot of like the
analysts associate roles you do pre-mba
you might present at a meeting but very
rarely are you ever up on a stage
delivering prepared remarks and uh and
over the course of a couple months you
go through the whole process of
of writing something of rehearsing it um
and then the wonderful thing uh you know
speaking to the community of the gsb
is at the end you give it in front of
you know 100 200 people
but it's like you know the most um
excited
friendly audience you could possibly
hope for i always liken it to like
it's like maybe half a notch below a
wedding audience when you're getting
like a wedding toast
like anything that might even be a
little bit funny gets like a huge laugh
that was like the audience for um for
this speech but it ended up being a
great
opportunity i talked about social media
um but the
topics really range and this is and this
is again this is like there's public
speaking courses but this was
kind of outside of the regular
curriculum just something that some of
the lecturers and professors have put
together
and was definitely from an education
standpoint i think one of the bigger
formative moments for me because it's
one of those things you do once and then
any other time i'm asked to speak for
something i feel much more confident
because i've gone through the process of
memorizing a 10-minute speech and
doing on stage and all that thank you
for the prompt
yeah i enjoyed it i'm going to turn
ayesha has oh
webb what's your most unique experience
yeah i'll add a playful uh spin on this
because there's so many unique
experiences
but one one of my favorites um is being
a part of the gsb
show which is a musical
comedy production entirely written
produced and performed by students
and the talent is just remarkable uh
fortunately for me they also let less
talented people participate
uh and so one of the one of the ways i
got to explore the gsb
was to try something that in my mind i
had told myself
and i objectively was very bad at which
was hip-hop dancing
uh and through a couple of clubs and you
know some very talented dancers with the
gsb
i was able to learn how to be a dancer
and i'm not
good but i'm i'm not bad anymore uh and
i got to the point where i
got to be you know a backup dancer in
two minutes of this
hour and a half long two-act performance
but it
honestly it was it was one of my one of
my highest of the gsb
and it put in my mind this like growth
mindset that
even there's something that i'm bad at i
have never thought of myself as good at
that if with the right amount of focus
and kind of help and support
i can grow into that that's awesome
that's
great well um five people voted for this
question from iesha
what are the specific leadership
development areas you wanted to focus on
when you
came and how did the gsb fulfill those
areas
or and or create awareness of other
leadership development areas
there's someone on the panel who feels
what they might want to answer that
personal question for you
tyrone
um in terms of things i wanted to work
on from a leadership perspective i think
for me
um you oftentimes get feedback at work
and i think it was glad you were saying
this earlier
around your work product but you really
don't know how you influence others how
you show up in the room what impact your
words have how you just are perceived
and so there are two or three things
that i found particularly impactful
for me to figure out you know how do i
get people to follow me like my whole
goal is to like lead organizations lead
the world but you know like lead
uh different initiatives um how do i get
people to to come behind me and do that
and i thought
the couple of experiences that were
really memorable for me was one was the
lead labs experience which i think we
touched on earlier
um you know charles talked about that um
but you're recording
like i don't know i haven't like
recorded myself and watched myself in
these
different role play scenarios before and
so just seeing how you're perceived on a
screen i think it's particularly
impactful um
and i thought that going through those
different challenges or mock exercise
just shows you how you show up in
different
high stress or different types of
situations and i would say the second
thing that was
also really helpful for me in figuring
out how i connected
and and uh you know what type of leader
i want to be we're just the startup
classes as well
um because i think you're forced to work
with your peers to actually get
something done get a business off the
ground and so i took
startup garage where we try to create a
car repair startup and i don't own a car
and i'm really bad at car repairs but we
still tried to do it and we were
fixing people's cars out of the gsb
parking lot and taking them to shops
out of palo alto but it just taught me
how to connect with my peers
and answer really tricky questions how
do you split equity how do you decide to
incorporate the company
what are you going to charge um and how
do you get you know that group of
individuals to all agree on something
it's particularly important and i still
find that those
those moments of really practical
learning and getting feedback live from
my classmates to be particularly
impactful for me
to this day um and i probably say i put
touchy feel in that same camp of just
getting
just constant feedback while you're at
the gsp they say it's a gift i've now
accepted you know feedback is a gift
that's like the gsb mantra and
and it does i think really improve your
leadership capabilities
awesome what do you wish you knew that
you know now
after being through the gsb i guess the
one thing i wish i
knew was uh
you're not gonna i guess this is uh i i
don't have like a great
philosophical answer but i just think
like being comfortable with the unknown
is okay um i think stanford's biggest uh
life advice that i got when i was there
is just like being
just getting comfort with taking risks
getting comfort which is not knowing
what's going to happen next
um and right now as you're going through
the process and just i know it sucks
like writing applications taking the
gmat or whatever
that's the hardest part um but even
though you may not know exactly where
you're gonna land or what
what essay you'll write um just being
comfortable with
not knowing that and enjoying the
process along the way because i think
that's when you learn the most um
and i always tell people it's not uh
it's enjoying the pursuit of happiness
it's not like you'll ever reach like
true happiness and so just enjoying
enjoying the ride
um and even things like so what matters
most to you and why like in hindsight i
really enjoyed answering that essay
question when it was happening i hated
it but
i was like really stressed out but like
in hindsight it like really centered me
um it forced me to put that on paper
um and so just yeah just being
comfortable with the amount
awesome thank you well we're getting a
bunch of questions about
application advice and i will say
perhaps the best place for those
is the webinars with the admissions that
are run for by an admissions officer
but there is one i'd like for anyone to
raise their hand and it's
for people who are tackling those tough
essays what matters most and why
any advice now i can't guarantee it was
good advice because these guys don't
know why they were admitted i'll put
that out there but
how do you get started tackling that
tough question
anyone like to rejoice
i think um so a very big theme of the
gsb is about knowing yourself
and knowing you know knowing yourself
and how you come across to others and
knowing the impact you want to have and
being really authentic
um i i felt like the touchy-feely essay
was one of the most difficult essays
i've ever had to write i went through so
many different drafts and
so many different iterations but it was
actually an incredible experience of
self-discovery
um and it took many months so i would
definitely recommend starting the
process early if you can
and for me what i found to be useful was
that i talked to a lot of people who
used to work with me
as well as people who i guess i was
starting early on
accepting that feedback is a gift and
asking them different questions about
what they thought you know stood out
about about me or what they felt my
values were and that was actually really
eye-opening too
and also kind of gratifying sometimes
unnerving but you know it's a it's a
good process
so best of luck to all of you awesome
and then uh one more on the covid
this is from george i believe um
for the current students do you have any
insight into what next year might look
like given the current atmosphere
so anyone who's currently on campus
kelsey
charles you guys want to take a stab at
what it's been like
sure yeah i'm happy to jump in i'm i'm
not on campus right at this moment but
um i have been chatting with classmates
who are
on campus or in the bay area and um you
know
i i don't want to you know say anything
that's not not exactly the
the school's evolving kind of policy on
this but it seems like
you know it's going to be some at least
in the fall some kind of hybrid mode of
instruction
um where there there might be an
in-person component to some classes for
example they've talked
about the class meets twice a week maybe
for one of those days it's in person for
part of the class and
online for the other part so what's one
thing that's cool about it is hearing
about um
we have about five or six classmates of
kelsey and our
my classmates in in an autumn quarter
task force right now serving with
faculty to
really try and like push the envelope
academically in terms of how we can make
this as engaging a quarter
as possible and maybe even lean into the
strengths of having more
um kind of online interaction however
that looks while being obviously like
incredibly safe and uh you know meeting
standards incredibly high bar for
uh for safety so i i think it continues
to evolve as a reality but
i'm i'm hopeful especially on the
community building point um i i
completely echo
the panelists comments and i think
kelsey was saying earlier just how
uh how big of a difference that's made
in the experience
awesome and i might um i might go go
ahead kelsey were you gonna say so i was
also just gonna say i really appreciated
it i mean i think
what the outcome of this is that remote
work is
definitely gonna be ingrained in us for
the years to come and it's gonna be
something that's got not going away
anytime soon and so learning how you
show up on
zoom is actually equally important as
learning how you show up in person
and that's something that i'm incredibly
grateful able to experience
at school part of my touchy feely
experience was overzoom
this past quarter and learning how you
interact with people
on film is going to be an essential
skill
moving forward so i'm appreciative of
that and then
and then also just being at school
during these types of environments we
talked we talked about
mg and and some of the leadership labs
managing learning how to manage those
tough conversations
you're in a community of 200 people who
have completely different risk
tolerances
and you're trying to create social norms
and establish
be both respectful of others opinions
and needs but also make your needs known
and this goes beyond you're no longer
role playing you're actually living
your stanford life lessons on campus and
i think that's something
that is both daunting but also gives me
a lot of optimism i think i learned so
much the spring quarter and that
um in that regard and so i'm excited to
go back and continue pushing myself and
testing that awesome thank you
so this is the cornerstone that's on our
campus that stanford is really dedicated
to you
our prospects out there dedicated to the
things that haven't happened yet
and the people who are about to dream
them up so hopefully you've heard some
things today that'll inspire you
as they've been inspired and if you want
to learn more we'd love to connect with
you
further so um we do have information
sessions that i've mentioned if you're
interested in hearing from an admissions
officer what we're looking for in the
application
this was an example of a regional panel
we're also doing industry panels
finance entertainment healthcare if
you'd like to hear from panelists in
those
industries to attend that would be great
for you to sign up as well
so please keep in touch um our motto
as you may know is changing lives
changing organizations changing the
world and i hope you
will take the next step i want to thank
all of our panelists this was so much
fun probably more fun for me than anyone
in the audience so thank you for your
time and everyone
have a wonderful day